(chants)
Addi Ba Mamadou
12ème régiment tirailleur sénégalais
Soyez sans craintes, on va s'occuper de vous
T'es complètement irresponsable Christine
On peut pas rester les bras croisés sans rien faire
à penser que les Allemands sont chez eux
Comme lui, il y en a plein d'autres
Les Allemands ont ratissé large mais des dizaines ont pu s'échapper
On les a retrouvé dans les champs, dans les forêts
Tu feras comme les autres, au boulot
Je savais que je pouvais compter sur toi
Bonjour Félix, nous cherchons à noyauter les administrations
recueillir le maximum d'informations de l'intérieur
Notre problème est de construire un réseau secret
Je travaille pour la Croix Rouge
Et lui ?
C'est mon traducteur
Traducteur ?
Ton pays c'est quelque part là-bas dans les colonies
Chez moi c'est ici
Bien sûr ...
Pourquoi vous dites ça ?
Bah parce que t'es noir
Je vous présente ma recrue
Je réponds comme d'un frère
À partir de maintenant vous obéirez au chef militaire du camp, Addi Ba
J'arrive pas à lui faire confiance
Pourquoi ?
Je fais confiance qu'aux Montagnards
Votre coup de feu,
il va faire 50 morts pour un soldat allemand tué
50 Français exécutés, ça désormais c'est la règle !
Les Allemands attendent un convoi de l'armement d'ici la fin de ce mois
C'est toi Cordet ?
Et toi le cardinal ?
Ah je voudrais
je voudrais n'être pas français pour pouvoir le dire
que je te choisis France
et que dans ton martyre, je te proclame
toi qu'orange le vautour
ma patrie et ma gloire
est mon unique amour
Et lui ?
C'est mon traducteur
Traducteur ?
Oui, pour parler avec les Africains
Ne cherchez pas c'est comme ça
C'est les accords entre Gouvernements
Français ?
Je m'appelle Jean Rousseau, je suis né à Orléans
Vous connaissez Zana ?
Non désolé
Ça va ?
T'inquiète pas, si ça se trouve il est déjà passé en zone libre ton copain
C'est pas seulement ça
J'ai une idée, suis moi